There has been so far a two-week
ceasefire between Iran and United
States.
The ceasefire is supposed to end
tomorrow.
And right now the Americans have gone to
a summer bad to negotiate a possible
peace treaty. The Iranians may go, they
may not go. We don't know yet.
It is entirely possible that the
Iranians will go to Zabbad and it's
entirely possible that they will
negotiate a ceasefire, a peace treaty
that ends the war. But unfortunately,
this war will not end.
So, a lot of people believe that this
war, it is just because Donald Trump has
decided to go to war with Iran for
whatever reason.
Um, but that's not true. This war in
Iran is actually part of a larger
strategic vision that the United States
has to maintain its empire. Okay. And
today I want to explain why that is the
case and how this war will progress. But
first I want to look at some recent
events from these past two weeks. One of
the big news these past two weeks is
that there are a lot of oil refineries
that have um that are a fire. Okay?
They've been a light. So even as the
world is being cut off from 20% of
energy from the Middle East, there are
lots of oil refineries that are being uh
destroyed. Okay, so this is from Russia
and this is actually Russia's largest
oil refinery. As you can see,
>> it is pretty extensive. Okay, but this
is not Russia. It is actually a lot of
places. So this is Myanmar and these are
10 oil tankers.
>> So
um there are a lot of oil refineries
that have uh that are being destroyed
right now. We don't know why this is
happening, but there's a lot. Okay,
there's there's over like there's
already been over 50 or fineries that
have been that have been on fire these
past uh 45 days. Another thing that's
been happening is that even though
there's a ceasefire in effect, the
Americans have imposed a blockade on
Iran and the Americans have escalated
the situation by boarding
and basically taking over an Iranian
ship returning from China. Okay, so
let's just look at some of the footage.
So what happened was that the Indian
ship was returning from China and the
Americans suspected that the ship had
important uh fuel and components for
ballistic missiles. The Americans tried
to board the ship. The ship would not
stop. The Americans fired at the engine
and then they boarded the ship with
special forces. Okay? And this is what
would be considered an act of piracy.
Um and before
the um secretary of war, Peter Hex, he
before complained
that you have to let ships freely
navigate in the seas, but he's also said
that it's perfectly okay for the
Americans to steal ships. Okay,
>> to be clear, threatening to shoot
missiles and drones at ships, commercial
ships that are lawfully transiting
international waters, that is not
control. That's piracy.
That's terrorism.
>> Certainly, that is
>> okay. So, you understand. So, the fact
that Iran has closed off the surf and
threatened to attack ships with drones
and ballistic missiles, that is wrong.
That is piracy. Unless the Americans do
this. Okay. Unless the Americans do
this.
>> Well is taking notice of that. And it
continues because two oil tankers two
overnight were seized by the United
States of America. Stateless or
sanctioned because the oil blockade, the
quarantine of oil out of unsanctioned or
stateless sanctioned or stateless uh
vessels continues. That leverage will
continue uh as Secretary Rubio outlined.
So as you've seen today,
>> okay. So does that make sense? It is
wrong for the world to be pirates and to
seize ships, but it's okay for the
United States to do this because the
United States is the one that sets the
rules for the world. Duh.
Okay.
So,
this war is not going well for the
United States.
This is uh Rick Scott and he's a senator
from Florida and he explains that it
doesn't really matter if the war is not
going well for the United States because
what's happening is that we're hurting
China and that's what's important.
>> How do you feel like the war in Iran,
which is sort of in a ceasefire right
now, how do you feel like this is going?
Should the US wrap this up, get out of
there now, or do you think there's more
to do there?
>> I think I I think I appreciate that
Trump's trying to get rid of the nuclear
weapons. I don't want to die by a
nuclear weapon from Iran. They wanted to
kill us. I mean I mean this appeasement
of bullies. I don't know if in your life
if that's worked for you guys. It's
never worked for me. And so they wanted
to kill us. So uh they're very and
they're getting close uh to be in a
position to kill us. And they basically
have been killing Americans. Uh so I
think what Trump did is the right thing.
Uh now I think this there he has to he
has to get the them in a position that
they don't have the ability to do
nuclear weapons or ballistic missiles.
That's I think that's where we have to
go. I don't know what the right approach
is going to be. Um I think blocking um
the straight horm is is um is fine from
my standpoint. If no if no oil ever goes
to China again and their economy is
destroyed, that would be a really
wonderful day for me.
>> Okay, you guys understand the Americans
may lose this war, but if the end result
is that China no longer gets any oil
from the Middle East and the economy is
destroyed, it's worth it. All right.
Okay. Even now, even at this late stage,
we're about 50 year 50 days into this
war. The Americans
have yet to explain why this war started
in the first place. So, so this is Karen
Livit and she was asked by a reporter
again why this war started
and this is this is her response.
>> Said yesterday for the first time that
he had to strike Iran because he
believes that Iran was going to strike
US targets within 7 days and then he
then bumped that down later to 3 days.
Where is he getting that? Well, that's
not the first time the president has
said that he chose to launch Operation
Epic Fury because he felt as though Iran
was going to strike the United States
and our assets in the region first.
Again, I addressed this in the last
briefing of this was a feeling the
president had based on facts. Facts
provided to him.
>> So, it was a feeling based on facts.
Okay, that's why Trump start this war.
>> Trump himself has given conflicting
signals.
Um he said uh that this war is going to
end soon. He's also said that this war
is going to continue. All right. So he
changed every day.
>> News uh 20 minutes ago, but it seems to
be going very well in the Middle East
with Iran.
We'll know over a little bit of time.
We're negotiating over the weekend.
And as you know, we have the blockade.
The blockade's been very successful and
of equal success has been the 5 weeks
before the blockade. The combination was
pretty lethal, I would say. So, we're
going to be knowing very shortly. So,
he's saying this war is going great. Um,
we should have a ceasefire soon. Okay.
And then maybe an hour later, he's like,
"Oh, I think I need to drop bombs on
Iran." So there's a lot of conflicting
signals coming from Trump. And what I
want to show you today, what I want to
argue uh to you today is that you have
to ignore these signals and focus on the
larger American strategy in this war.
And once you once we understand the
strategy, then it's very easy for us to
understand how this war will progress
over the next few years. Okay? Because
this war is not going to end soon. It
won't be a few months. It'll probably be
a few years. And quite honestly, um it
may take 10 or 20 years. Okay. So, let's
look over some more news. So as I
mentioned previously,
oil refineries are getting sabotaged
either by accident or purposefully. Um
what this tells us is that in the for
past 45 days there have been at least 45
recorded incidents around the world of
oil refineries being set on fire. Okay.
So Iran uh was bombed by the Israelis
and then the Israelis responded by
attacking Qatar. Uh Russia is being
attacked by Ukraine and um the big one
is that in Australia in Jon one of the
refineries was uh set on fire and they
claim it was an accident. This is
important because Australia is not at
war but Australia needs a lot of oil.
Okay. So right now Australia is in a lot
of trouble. Um Romania, Bucharest has
been hit, India has been hit, Marmar has
been hit. Okay, so all around the world
there are these fires going on
destroying the world's oil supply. So
why is this happening? Um and who's
doing this? We don't know. And quite
honestly, we may never know. But to
figure out the answer, you always ask
yourself
um who benefits, right? And you always
look at three things.
means,
motive,
and opportunity.
And so from this, you could figure out
that the majority of these fires are
being set um are being deliberately set
in order to reduce the world's oil
supply. And the people who can do this,
the people who benefit from doing this
are the the Russians or the Americans.
Okay? One of these two. It's probably
both, but we don't know for sure yet.
All right. Um, this war as we discussed
previously is have is having already
having a tremendous impact on the
world's economy. So, sulfur
um has risen in price by 57%.
Sulfur is important for the manufacturer
of both fertilizers as well as for
microchips.
Okay. Uh, jet fuel has grown gone by
52%. So next time you're flying United
States, it's going to be a much more
expensive ticket. Uh URA is more of a
fertilizer. Uh diesel, gasoline,
fertilizer. So basically um food
and uh energy their price have gone way
up. Okay.
Donald Trump makes a statement saying
that the Iranian flag cargo ship Tusca
has been boarded by the Americans. Okay.
And Donald Trump continues to threaten
the Iranians and say that if you
continue to close out the Hammoose
um then we will negotiate with bombs
basically.
All right.
No more Mr. Nice Guy. And quite
honestly, what what he's also saying is
we don't really care because we don't
need that oil from the Middle East.
Also, we can sell our oil
um to the world. Okay. The United States
loses nothing. In fact, many ships are
headed right now to the US, Texas,
Louisiana, Alaska to load up compliments
of the RGC. We just want to be the tough
guy. All right. So, we're we're the ones
benefiting from this war. So, we have
nothing to worry about.
All right. So another thing that I want
you guys to pay attention to is how
America is moving towards a war economy.
All right. So um the Pentagon has been
in talks with General Motors and Ford to
make munitions, drones, and military
equipment.
Right? So this is what this this last
happened in World War II when America
moved to total war. Their factories that
used to make cars were now making tanks.
But not only that, but Trump also
announced something called the Defense
Production Act as of today. And what
this does is it basically allows
government to subsidize
private corporations in the manufacturer
of weapons. Okay? So these companies,
General Motors, Ford, um they can make a
lot of money because of this war. That's
that's something to keep keep in mind.
Starting December, Americans who are
aged 18 to 26 will be automatically
registered for the draft. Okay? So, it's
very likely that America will soon
introduce a national draft and force
young man to go fight in the Middle
East.
Currently, the Pentagon budget is $1
trillion. Next year, it'll be $1.5
trillion. increase by of um 50%.
Okay. And we can expect that thereafter
it might be $2 trillion.
Um
more veterans are now being asked to
serve longer. Okay. So what we're seeing
is that the United States is moving
towards a wartime economy. Okay. Okay,
they're preparing for what we call total
war when an economy moves towards
uh the manufacturer of weapons and
munitions.
All right. Another thing that's that's
been happening that you should pay
attention to is the fact that there's
very little opposition. In fact, there's
no opposition to Donald Trump fighting
this war in Iran. You would think that
the Democrats, his opponents, would use
this opportunity to promote anti-war
messages or try to stop him from uh
plunging America into another forever
war in the Middle East. Instead, the
Democrats are doing as much as possible
not to do anything. So, recently in
Congress, they had a vote as to whether
or not to restrict Trump's ability to
fight this war. Okay? And there were
four Republicans
who did not vote and one Republican
who voted we should restrict Trump.
Okay. And so this vote should have been
214 to 213
in favor. Yes, we will restrict Trump's
war powers. But then what happened was
that one Democrat, just one Democrat
decides I'm going to switch MY VOTE TO
NO. So now now becomes 214 to 213. Okay?
Do you understand guys? This is all
political theater. Do you understand?
It's all theater. Meaning that it was
already pre-arranged between the
Republicans and Democrats that this
resolution would fail. In other words,
if maybe two Republicans voted yes, then
two Democrats would have voted no. If 10
Republicans voted uh yes, then 10
Democrats would have voted no. You
understand? The Democrats are not
opposing this war. They're doing as much
as possible to support this war. So the
the question then is why is this
happening? Why is America moving towards
a wartime economy? Why are the Democrats
so supportive of this war? And the
answer has to do with empire. Okay.
So this is something called the national
defense strategy that came out in
January 2026. And this is a blueprint
for how the Pentagon will fight wars for
the next 5 to 10 years. This is a
strategy behind the Iran war. All right.
And so what we're going to do is we're
going to read certain parts together to
analyze how the Americans will
strategize about the world moving
forward. Okay. So, um um Ivory, could
you help help me read, please? Thank
you.
>> For too long, the US government
neglected, even rejected putting
Americans in their concrete interests
first. Previous administrations
squandered our military advantages and
the lives, goodwill and resources of of
her people in grandio nation building
projects and self- congratulatory
pledges to uphold cloud castle
abstractions like the rulebased
international order. These p these past
leaders neglected and often actively
undermined our war fighters warrior
ethos and our military's core
irreplaceable role fighting winning and
thereby deterring the wars that really
matter to our people. Consequently,
President Trump entered office with the
nation on the precipice of distress
disastrous wars for which we were
unprepared.
>> Okay, so certain things to keep in mind.
Okay, concrete interest first means that
we have to think about
resources. We have to think about
concrete advantages to America. We can
we can no longer think about ideals.
Okay.
Second is the idea of rulesbased
international order or the globalist.
Before America was fighting wars for
their nations or for Europe or for
Japan, we had to fight wars for America.
Okay. And the last thing is the idea of
um
uh undermine our warriors ethos. Okay.
Undermine our warrior ethos. What this
means is that before America was bounded
by too many rules. Okay. What what they
call rules of engagement.
Okay. or basically
avoiding war crimes.
You were not allowed to kill civilians.
You needed permission from the nations
to fight wars. And what this is saying
is like screw that. Okay? Screw rules of
engagement. We should just fight wars to
win wars. That means we kill as many
people as we need. That means we do
whatever is necessary in order to win
wars. Okay. So this is what the first
paragraph is saying here. It's a new
vision of American power. Before it was
about ideals. Now it's about interest.
Before it was about globalism. Now it's
about America first. Before it was about
rules of engagement. Now it's about the
warrior ethos. Okay. Uh please continue
reading. Ivory.
>> President Trump has decisively changed
that courageously putting Americans
first to truly make America great once
again. Under his leadership, the United
States has the world's strongest, most
lethal, and most capable military.
Indeed, the most powerful military that
this world has ever seen. No longer will
the department be distracted by
interventionism, endless wars, regime
changes, and nation building. Instead,
we will put our people's practical,
concrete interests first. We will
support a policy of actual peace through
strength. We will be the sword and
shield to deter war with the goal of
peace but ready to fight and win the
nation's necessary wars if called upon.
This is
>> stop. Okay. Right. So the important
sentence here is we will support a
policy of actual peace through strength.
What this means is that we will be so
mighty. We will be so invincible. We
will be so fearless that we will instill
fear in others. they'll be so afraid to
fight us and therefore we'll have peace.
Okay. So it's the idea of hegemony,
peace through might, peace through
power. We have to demonstrate we are
invincible. When people fear us, that's
when people will obey us. When people
obey us, that's when we have peace.
Okay.
>> This does not mean isolationism. To the
contrary, it means a focused and
genuinely strategic approach to the
threats our nation faces and how to best
manage them. This approach is based on a
flexible, practical realism that looks
at the world in a cleareyed way which is
essential for serving Americans's
interests as the national security
strategy articulates. This is the common
sense approach President Trump has
advanced.
>> Okay. All right. So, this does not mean
isolationism. It's about how to best
manage them. So the idea here is that
America before was engaging too many
wars overseas. It was too spread out.
America will now be focused on
maintaining and protecting its core
strategic interest. That means divide
and conquer. Okay? Divide and conquer.
Divide and rule. Okay? I'll explain this
as we go on. All right? So
these are the four strategic interests
of United States. Okay. Can you read
that?
We will defend the homeland and ensure
that our interests in the western
hemisphere are protected. We will deter
China in the Indoacific through strength
and not confrontation. We will increase
burden sharing with allies and partners
around the world. And we will rebuild
the US defense industrial base as part
of the president's once in a century
revival of American industry.
>> Okay, so this is it. Okay, this is a
plan moving forward and already we're
seeing the Americans are doing this. All
right. So, uh, we build the US defense
industrial base. Okay. Basically means
factories and resources. All right.
Making sure that America becomes the
um arsenal of democracy. Its factories
produce all the weapons America needs in
order to protect its interests as well
as protect its allies. Um,
we will increase burden sharing with
allies and partners around the world.
Okay. This basically means that from now
on we're not friends. From now on, we're
the boss and you do what we tell you to
do. Okay?
From now on, we will order Japan, South
Korea, Europe, NATO to do what they must
in order to protect our power and they
must follow us. Basically, a criticism
of vaselage.
That's number two. Number three is we
will deter China in the Indo Pacific
through strength, not confrontation. We
don't want to destroy China. We don't
want to hurt China. But we need China to
obey us. And the way to do that is by
containing China, strangling China
economically and also promoting Japan.
Okay? So in the future, China
and Japan will balance each other out
and that allows us to rule over them,
right? In the future, we America will
sell resources, weapons and financing to
both China and Japan as they compete
against each other in East Asia. That's
how we will we will contain China. And
then the idea of we'll defend the home
homeland and ensure that our interests
in western hemisphere are protected.
Okay. So basically this means that the
western hemisphere
belongs to America. We'll do whatever we
want in the western hemisphere. If you
want to come to Western Hemisphere, you
need our permission. If you China or
Russia, you want to come into Western
Hemisphere, you have to get our
permission. Yet you have to pay a tax to
us. Okay, this is really important.
Defend the homeland. Defend the homeland
just basically means a police state.
Before America was too free and
therefore America was too weak. The
example is the Vietnam War when the war
was not lost in Vietnam. The war was
lost at home because you had too many
people, too many young men protesting in
on the streets. Too many rebels. If we
want to win wars, if we want to project
strength, if you want to create peace in
the world, we need to make sure that our
home front is secure. All right? And
that means making sure that Americans
follow along, do what they're told.
Okay? So, uh I'll explain this more as
we go along. All right? So, now let's
move on to China. Okay. So, so can you
can you read ivory?
>> Deter China in the indo-acific through
strength, not confrontation.
President Trump seeks a stable peace,
fair trade, and respectable relations
with China. And he has shown that he is
willing to engage President Cining
directly to achieve those goals. But
President Trump has also shown how
important it is to negotiate from a
position of strength and he has tasked D
accordingly.
Consistent with the president's
approach, D will therefore seek and open
a wider range of militarytoilitary
communications with the people's
liberation army with a focus on
supporting strategic stability with
Beijing as well as deconliction and
deescalation more generally. But we will
also be cleareyed and realistic about
the speed, scale, and quality of China's
historic mil military buildup. Our goal
in doing so is not to dominate China,
nor is it to strangle or humiliate them.
Rather, our goal is simple. To prevent
anyone, including China, from being able
to dominate us or our allies. in essence
to set the military condition required
to achieve the iness goal of a balance
of power in the Indo-Pacific that allows
all of us to enjoy a decent peace. To
that end, as the NSS directs, we will
erect a strong denial defense along the
first island chain. We will also urge
and enable key regional allies and
partners to do more for our collective
defense. In doing so, we will reinforce
the deterrence by denial so that all
nations recognize their interests are
best served through peace and and
restraint.
>> Okay. So again, this is a very clear
plan. Okay. What this is saying is this.
We're going to negotiate with China.
We're going to be friends. We have to do
so from a position of strength. And so
what does that mean? First of it means
that we will embargo China. Okay. How
can we embargo China? Through the first
island chain. Right? The first island
chain is Japan, Taiwan, the Philippines.
Right? So if you embargo China, it means
China cannot access the SH of Malaca,
which provides China with 80% of its
energy needs, right? And so if you
embargo China, China has no choice but
to obey you. You're negotiating from
position of strength. The other thing is
that we're going to enable key regional
allies and this of course be Japan
uh South Korea
uh Taiwan,
Malaysia,
Singapore,
Indonesia, right? And this creates a
sort of malaca.
We will have these nations challenge
Chinese supremacy in order to create
balance, a power balance in East Asia.
And once this power balance is created,
they all depend on us, United States,
because we have energy, we have food, we
have weapons, we have financing.
Okay. So again, if you just read this,
it's very very clear what the United
States wants to do and they're already
doing it. All right. So this is a
conclusion. Okay. Aubrey, can you read
please?
Taking our nation from the precipice of
a world war just a year ago, President
Trump is now leading our nation into a
new golden age. One defined by putting
Americans first in a common sense,
pragmatic and concrete way. No longer
will we squander Americans will
resources and even lives in foolish and
grandiose adventures abroad. But we will
not retreat. Rather, we will unabashly
prioritize Americans as concrete
interest with an approach of flexible
realism. We will restore the warrior
ethos. We will refocus the American
military on its core irreplaceable goal
of winning the nation's wars decisively.
In doing so, as President Trump has so
memorably emphasized, our purpose will
not be aggression or perpetual war war.
Rather, our goal is peace. Peace is the
highest good. But not a peace that
sacrifices our people's security,
freedoms, and prosperity. Rather, a
peace that Americans deserve, a noble
and proud peace. Fortunately, this peace
is compatible with the interests of our
potential opponents if they keep their
demands reasonable and and cabined. We
do not demand their humiliation or
submission. Rather, we demand only that
they respect our reasonably conceived
interests and those of our allies and
partners who stand stoutly with us.
If we all can acknowledge this, we can
achieve a flexible and sustainable
balance of power among us and peace. But
we at the Department of War will be
ready if our gracious offer is burned.
We know that wishing for a decent peace
is not the same thing as bringing it
about. Thus, if our potential opponents
are unwise enough to reject our peaceful
overtures and choose conflict instead,
America's armed force will stand ready
to fight and win the nation's wars in
ways that make sense for Americans. To
ensure that this is the case, the
strategy will ensure that we see things
and the choices we need to make clearly.
We will prioritize addressing the most
consequential and grave threats to
Americans as interests. We will revamp
our network of allies and partners to
meet the threats we face. And we will be
ready, always carrying the sharpest and
most formidable sword, but prepared to
offer the olive branch.
>> Okay, so this is very clear. Okay, what
he's saying is this. Obey us and there
will be peace. Defy us and there will be
war. Okay, the the key idea is we will
prioritize prioritize addressing the
most consequential and great threats to
Americans interests. Okay. Sorry. Can
Can you give back?
Okay. So, I want to show you what this
means. Basically, it means that from now
on, America will adopt
um a new strategy. Okay. All right. So,
if this ceasefire does not work and war
um continues, then we we can expect in
round two the fighting will get much
worse. Okay? Right. So the Americans
will start to target civilian
infrastructure including bridges,
universities, reservoirs, power plants,
dissalation plants. Basically, it will
destroy Iran's capacity to be a nation
state. In response, the Iranians can
destroy a lot more energy
infrastructure. Okay. So what it's done
now, it's basically closed off the
straight of Humus, but it can also close
off the Red Sea. Okay. And it can also
target pipelines of natural gas.
Basically, it can take offline onethird
of the world's energy supply. And this
would of course cause an economic
depression. Okay. Unfortunately, the
national security strategy of of the
United States doesn't really care.
If you just read the national security
strategy, they already have factored
this in and they don't really care. So
the idea is to prioritize strategic
interest. And what this basically means
is that America has the world's greatest
navy. No one else comes close. And so
all they have to do is contain the
world's choke points and the world must
bend to the will of America. Okay? Does
that make sense? You're going to trade
then you must depend on American
generosity.
Okay? So already what's happening is
that this area it's being closed off but
America has made moves to close off
other areas as well. So so America's
exerting more control over the Panama
Canal. Okay. Basically the western
hemisphere
um is under something called the Donro
doctrine. The Don doctrine basically
states that
America can do whatever it wants in the
Western Hemisphere. If you want to come
here and trade, you have to go through
us. China depends on a lot of resources
from the western hemisphere, especially
from South America. All right. Over
here, something called the lithium
triangle.
Um, this is Venezuela.
Brazil provides China with a lot of
agricultural products, soil beans.
Basically, what Trump is saying is that,
hey, in the future, you want to trade
over here, China, you have to go for us.
Okay? So, he's basically embarling the
western hemisphere from China. Over here
is something we call the straight of
Malaa. This is the most important choke
point in the world especially for East
Asia because as you can see
the Middle East if it is to access South
Korea, China and Japan has to go through
the strip of Mala. But guess what guys
everything goes through the straight of
Mala. And this is important because
United States has signed a deal with
Indonesia. So, so what we can expect is
that America and Indonesia in Indonesia
their militaries will start to cooperate
more and more. This is move and and
that's and the reason why is America is
moving towards creating the first island
chain basically um in militi
militarizing the first island chain in
order to deter China to embargo China
basically. What we're also seeing is
that Japan
is now rapidly remilitizing.
Uh they're signing more agreements with
Australia and other nations. Okay?
They're building more weapons. This is
all being encouraged by the United
States as a deterrent to China. Again,
this is really important. America does
not want to destroy China. It does not
want to d to humiliate China. It wants
to control China because the Chinese
economy is still very strong and
powerful and America wants to make sure
that the Chinese are buying more US
dollars. Okay, so it is entirely
possible what's going to happen is that
the Chinese will have no choice but to
buy from America. Okay, especially
energy. The entire western hemisphere
belongs to America and you you want to
trade with with western hemisphere then
you you need to sign a trade deal with
America.
Okay. Um what America is also doing
that's really important is that it's
planning to take over Greenland. Okay.
By taking over Greenland, you're
blocking access um uh China and Russia
cannot access uh the western hemisphere.
Okay. for the Arctic. You're also taking
seizing control over the Arctic. Okay.
And there are lots of um minerals and
oil in the Arctic as well. Okay. Um the
street of uh Jialter is also another
strategic uh choke point and America has
signed a deal with Morocco to enhance
more cooperation. Okay. So I can see
what America is doing is when they mean
strategic interest, priorizing strategic
interest, what they mean is exerting
control over the world's choke points so
that they can control global trade.
Okay? They're not going to control the
entire ocean because it's much too big.
But if they control certain choke points
like the Middle East, uh the Middle
East, um and the Malaka, that's probably
enough. Okay. The point is to get China
to submit. The point is to control
China, not to destroy China. All right,
this is important because
um if you want to become a major power
in the world, you need to trade
effectively. So Russia has something
called the north south corridor. As you
can see, it runs through Iran. Okay,
Iran is very important for the Russian
north south corridor.
Um, and that's why the United States is
attacking Iran and that's why the United
States is not is not is not going to
ever stop attacking Iran because as long
as Iran is at peace, Russia can trade
with the world. But if R if Iran is
being destroyed, there's too much war.
This entire region is blocked off from
both Russia and China. Okay. Uh Russia
is going to call the Belt and Road
Initiative. As you can see, okay, from a
map, the center of the belt and road
initiative is of course Iran.
All right.
If
China wants to access Africa, Europe,
the Middle East, it has to go through
Iran
or it goes through the sea, the straight
of Malaca. But as already said, the next
step for America is to close off the
straight of Malaa as well through
Chinese trade. Then where do you go?
Well, then you go over to western the
western hemisphere, but that's American
territory. Okay? Yes, you can trade with
Russia.
You can trade with Russia. You can do
that, but it's not enough for your
economy. Doesn't make sense. Right now,
China gets about 20% of its oil from
Russia. Maybe Russia can provide 30% or
40%. At most, that's very optimistic.
But you need But where are you going to
get the other 50% 60%. Okay. Your
options are very limited. If Iran is at
war, can't give you any oil, then you're
forced to buy from the United States.
Okay? If you're if you're forced to buy
from the United States, United States
can set the price. It can set terms. It
can dictate terms to you. And what the
United States will say, you have to buy
in US dollars.
Okay? And that saves their economy,
right? Does it make sense, guys? This
this is not a hard idea to understand.
This is exactly what it says in the US
national security strategy. Okay?
So
in many ways you can make the argument
that what's happening around the world
right now it's all an American policy of
containing China where in the U these
flags are US military bases as you can
see China's completely surrounded
by US military bases in Japan in South
Korea in Taiwan even in uh Indonesia and
Malaysia China Philippines China's
completely surrounded Okay. And this is
it, the street of Mala. This is a major
choke point. And as you can see, it's
not that hard for America to cut off
that choke point, right? You see how
much trade goes through the Malaa. You
can see how many US bases are are here.
And this and you can see a lot of this
trade goes to the Middle East. But hey,
guess what? The Middle East is at war
right now. So no more oil, no more
energy, no more LG from the Middle East.
So you might go to uh Angola, but this
is very important. The Americans have
recently announced a naval blockade
in the Indian Ocean. Okay? So that's
kind of your route as well. So if you're
China, yes,
um you could rely on Russia, but you see
how little this is. Okay, there's too
little trade between Russia and China.
And you can build it up, but it's going
to take you 10 20 years time. And then
and what do you do for the next 10
years, right? Your people needs need
food to eat. You need energy to fuel
your factories.
And so for the next 10 years, you have
no choice but to work with the United
States. And that's what Trump means by
negotiating
from a position of strength because you
can set terms. You can force China to
accept whatever terms you want. And
quite honestly, if you just look at this
map,
there's very little that China can do
about it. Okay, this is war in the
Middle East. There's also this war in
Russia, which also absorbs a lot of
Russian energy. So Russia doesn't have
that much resources to spear to China
anyway, but America does, the Western
Hemisphere does, okay? Because the
Western Hemisphere is at peace. So as
long as the Western Hemisphere maintains
a fortress, okay? Meaning it it no one
can attack uh the Western Hemisphere,
then Western Hemisphere can continue to
supply resources to the world at war.
So this is what the war is about, guys.
Okay? It's about
creating conflict in the world so the
United States can maintain its empire.
And the way it maintains its empire is
by maintaining its control over global
trade. Okay? And the idea is
America in the future will provide the
world with energy,
resources,
weapons,
and financing.
Meaning, we will actually lend you the
money to buy this stuff as well. And
what do we call this stuff? US dollars.
Okay.
And so this worked really well in 1950s
under something called the Marshall
Plan. Okay, the Marshall Plan. Same idea
where
America made products and it lent money
to Europe to buy uh products from
America. same concept appear where in
the future
the world is at war, people are poor,
but it's okay because America will lend
you money to buy energy resources and
weapons from America. Okay? And American
factories will go up. America will be
great again. Make America great again.
All right?
Okay. But for this plan to fully work
out,
America needs three things. Okay? The
first thing that it needs to do is
create a national draft. Does that make
sense, guys? Because you need soldiers
in order to maintain America's core
interests, right? So, whichever nation
is defying you, you go attack, right?
The goal is for Russia and Europe to
constantly fight each other. The goal is
for China and and Japan to constantly
fight each other. You and you need Iran
to constantly fight with the GCC and
Issue. Okay? So, you have these three
major conflicts around the world. But if
there's any nation that's at peace,
well, then you have to create conflicts.
Okay? Maybe in Africa,
um you also want to control the Western
Hemisphere. So, you need soldiers to go
and conquer nations that defy you. Okay?
Okay. So the first thing that you need
is a national draft. All right. Second
thing that you need is something called
continuity of agenda. What does this
mean? It means like now that you have
this plan in motion, you cannot have a
change in government. Okay? So let's
just say they're implementing this plan
and they're doing that right now. In
2028,
the Democrats win. Well, that would
screw things up. Okay? So Trump needs a
third term, right? A Trump third term
because only he
can implement this plan and make America
great again.
Okay. And the third thing that you need
is an AI surveillance state.
Basically a AI police state. Why?
Because again,
this plan can only work if the Americans
don't rise up and revolt like they did
in the Vietnam War. Okay? If you have a
national draft in place, if if Trump's
going for a third term, they're going
there there's going to be a lot of
Americans who are going to protest in
the streets, who are going to rebel,
right? You can't have that happen.
They'll screw things up. Therefore, you
need an AI surveillance state in order
to help them see the light, right?
So,
ICE, guys. Okay, ICE.
People believe that ICE is being sent to
the streets of America in order to catch
illegal immigrants. The problem with
this is that you don't need ICE. You
just need cooperation from the state
authorities. Okay. What ICE is really
doing is basically um creating
conditions for a police state. It's
normalizing or making common the idea of
armed
soldiers patrolling the streets of
America in all the major cities. All
right. And the reason why why we think
this or we can suspect this is look at
their budget, man. Look at this budget.
Before the budget was kind of stable,
then boom, it goes up to 90 $90 billion.
That's a lot of money. Okay, that's
almost like a new national police force
that is only obedient to Donald Trump.
It's basically Donald Trump's private
police force in order to implement his
vision. Okay.
Also, data centers, guys. Data centers.
Now, I know that some of you are big
fans of artificial intelligence, but
artificial intelligence doesn't really
make any money, right? Chat PT, you
don't you can't make money off that.
>> You can't make money off digital
girlfriends
or digital pets,
right?
So, why is America building all these
data centers around the world? In fact,
the federal government under Trump has a
plan called Operation Stargate where
they will build $500 billion. Okay? They
would invest $500 billion in building
data centers around the United States.
Well, you would want to build data
centers if you want to create a AI
surveillance state, right? where
everyone has digital ID, digital
currency and where everyone can be
monitored to avoid people from rebelling
against Trump.
Okay? And that is the um idea. Okay? And
you um listen to this and you think, "Oh
my god, America is doomed or Donald
Trump's going to become king for the
rest of his life. There's nothing we can
do." Well, the problem is this. The
problem is that this idea of imperial
conquest, it's actually not a new idea,
guys. Okay, it really isn't. Empires
have been doing this for a long, long
time. It has not worked out well.
Okay. So the goal again to summarize is
to create a situation where you have
greater North America
or what they call the technate.
Okay. And this becomes a fortress. You
have infinite resources, infinite
manpower and you can sell weapons,
uh resources and financing to the rest
of the world. And you want to create as
much conflict in the world as possible.
Right? So here it'll be between China
and Japan.
Here it'll be between Iran, Israel, and
the GCC. Okay? Here it will be between
Europe and Russia. Basically, you want a
world forever at war so that you can
control the world. And all America has
to do is control key choke points. Okay?
key strategic choke points like the show
of Malaa
uh Hussear
Panama. Why? Because once you control
the choke point, you can control which
nations get what resources. If if a
nation is is becoming too strong, you
give them less resources. If a nation is
too weak, you give them more resources.
And as a result, you can always maintain
the balance of power in each region.
Right? So, it sounds like a great plan,
but it's not going to work out. Why?
Well, because of something called
nationalism.
Okay? Because when you do this, when you
are an empire and you impose your will
on other nations, these nations are not
happy about it.
Right? So imagine Japan,
South Korea, Europe
there. People know that they're being
used, right? So eventually they'll be
like screw this. We want to be
independent. We want peace. So they will
eventually rise up against the empire.
And the way they will do this is they
will work together to
destroy America or basically to remove
America from the world. You can't you
can't actually attack America. Now what
America can do is say screw you. We're
the entire western hemisphere. We have
infinite resources. We can make infinite
weapons and you can never attack us. So
we'll come and attack you. Okay. They
could do that. The problem then is you
have division
and corruption.
Okay. So an empire in decline always
suffers from corruption and division.
Corruption just means that yes, you've
allocated $1.5 trillion
to making weapons, but guess what? The
vast majority of that will be stolen by
people,
right? The America America right now is
is in a lot of trouble because it's a
very corrupt place. Division means that
uh the Democrats and Republicans fight
all the time. What we call political
political
polarization.
So it is possible that as America is
being asked to fight more wars overseas,
you have civil war
in America. The other thing is when
America takes over the entire North
America including Canada, Greenland,
Mexico, Cuba,
Colombia, Venezuela,
um Honduras, they won't be happy
about it. Okay? So you're going to have
insurgencies.
All right? And this three problems,
nationalism, corruption, and division
means that when America actually tries
to implement this plan, it's going to
backfire. It's going to it's going to
accelerate the collapse of the American
empire,
right?
And then you ask yourself, okay, if
historically
we know that empires will collapse,
why do they do this? And the answer is
because
it benefits them in the short term.
Okay, this is a short-term solution that
creates long-term problems, but who
cares about the long term? Let's just
enjoy the short term. Okay?
All right. Does that make sense? Okay.
Um, any questions?
>> But for the war between Iran and
>> America, you previously said that
America will lose the war. But, uh,
according to the analysis that you just
did, like America will try to control
nations around China and those nations,
but it will finally backfire. So the
result of that predictions will still be
America will lose right.
>> Um yeah. So so again the major
prediction is that America may in the
short term seem as though it is winning
but in the long term because of
corruption, division and nationalism,
America will be forced to retreat back
to the western hemisphere and it will
lose its empire. All right.
And yes um America will lose the war in
Iran. Okay. and be forced to retreat
from Iran. It but it doesn't really have
to win the war. It doesn't have to
defeat Iran. It just has to make Iran
constantly in a state of of chaos and
war. Okay? Does that make sense? Because
the point is to control the choke
points. Okay? The key are the choke
points. This is these are these are the
keys. This is what America must protect.
And what happens in Europe, Russia,
China, Japan, Iran doesn't really
matter. What? But what America wants to
do is create as much chaos as possible
in these places so that they depend on
America for resources, for financing,
for weapons. Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay. America doesn't really care
anymore if it loses its war in Iran.
That's that's not the big that's not the
point. The point is to maintain control
over the strategic control points so the
world depends on American resources to
survive.
Okay.
Yeah.
Does China or any other countries uh
discerns that America is trying to
control the trade route of China?
Oh, look.
Okay. What America is doing is obvious.
All right. It's it's silly. It's it's
really obvious to people, right? There's
nothing you can do about it.
There's nothing you can do about it
because America has a blue water navy
that controls the oceans. So the
question then is what happens what
happens in the long term? Well, in the
long term what what's going to happen is
that Russia
uh Russia will challenge
America
in these choke points. Okay. And this
already happening in Cuba. Okay. Cuba is
here and right and we we'll discuss this
next class but Cuba is under embargo
right now and Cuba is trying to uh
become closer with Russia. Okay. So what
Russia is going to do is set up
basically its own navy to challenge the
American Navy and Russia cannot win
against the American Navy but what it
can do is fight a war of attrition
against the American Navy raising cost.
Okay that's number one. Number two is
that if American can go and blow up
energy supplies around the world to make
the world more dependent on America,
well, Russia can also blow up energy
supplies to make the world dependent on
Russia. Okay? So, what's going to happen
is that Russia and America are going to
compete against each other.
All right? And most of the world is
ultimately going to side with Russia in
order to balance United States because
United States is too much of a bully.
And at this point, in the short term,
China has no choice but to work with
both Russia and America because China is
not strong enough to challenge either.
Does that make sense? Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Alan,
>> so my question is about how Trump going
to uh going to like deal with the
internal conflict in American like
there's right now he only had like 37%
of uh supporting rate and and Democrats
seems didn't agree with his plan. So how
he going to do about this and uh what is
um if Democrat party doesn't agree with
Trump's plan what is the plan of
Democrat to American?
>> Okay. Yeah. So first of all Democrats
have no plan. Okay. This this is why
Americans in so much trouble because
America the Democrats have actually no
plan of themselves. Okay. So even if the
Democrats were to win office in 2028,
what they'll probably do is continue
Trump's plan because they themselves
don't have any plan. Trump's plan to
stay in power is just basically cheat.
He'll cheat. Okay? He'll rip the
elections. He'll he'll cheat. That's
that's his plan moving forward. And
he'll probably get away with it. Okay.
Okay. Any more questions, guys? All
right. So, we'll continue this next
class.